okay for people watching on the
livestream yet another in our series of
incremental language development
internal design meetings getting ready
for the freeze of the next version of
wolf language which is supposed to be
happening tomorrow um some of these
things will not be relevant to that we
were just talking about what has become
a a an old if spicy chestnut the naming
of the function curry I I think we're
not gonna solve this right now um let
let us try I really had wanted to have a
chance to think about this I have not
had a chance to think about it um I
would really like to have a name that
can if somebody sees it in a piece of
code that they understand something
about what it is without having to ask
the question but I'd I'd like to ask you
know what would be the elevator version
of what does curry do so if you see okay
not the elevator version if you see you
know somebody sees curry of f of X of Y
okay or they see partition of I mean
this is much more obscure the curry
second partition three comma list you
know range of twenty or something okay
what do you tell somebody about what
that does how do you explain it
anybody wanted try that Isis I think
it's easier to explain what curry second
partition three does it's it's a
function that will do something with an
argument good fantastic yes no I'd first
to eliminate the range twenty so curry
second partition three is an operator
form of partition that will is a written
form of partition
that we partition an expression in you
don't get to use that though cuz this is
gonna be general so you don't get the
same partition we got a bunch of
background noise cuts whoever's cut back
on noise mute thanks um
okay go ahead yeah so if we have F so
it's an operator mmm it's an AB rating
form of F well it would be curry carries
of curry second with an opposite well
even the curry even the regular curry
yes so yes okay so this might be curry
of F is an operator form of F that
sequentially
how many arguments does it except by
default - that's pretty useless well
remember that before we had Kari F
representing distrubing I know I know I
know I know well it makes more sense but
I mean honestly it makes more sense to
default this to one argument to one I
mean it's kind of stupid then because
then Curry of F is extract Lee to 2f
right but then how do we do it
I mean the or we could we can't default
it to as many as you give because that
doesn't make sense either does it
yes we're gonna do that we need to know
at the very beginning but I think two is
the most frequent case most of our
current operator forms have two
arguments and we can really understand
but they but they typically do a curry
second in that case exactly yes
I'm thinking that shop argument sounds
reasonably nice
we could have curry arguments it doesn't
help us doesn't help us I mean it really
doesn't help us it's still completely
obscure because what you see is curry I
mean if we said swap arguments um
someone on the livestream swish car is
suggesting curry equals conjunction bond
what does that mean I do not know what
that means
anyway I don't know what that means
um I'd like to know what that means
um okay we're gonna burn all of our time
talking about curry here yes look worst
case which is kind of silly it seems
crazy to put the sinners and as a
function in the experimental context
because well we actually can't figure
out the semantics either not only do we
not know the name we don't even know the
semantics although I have to say that
curry as a thing by the way this is
incorrect that first line there that's
the swapped form right yes if this
hasn't been updated it will be lovely if
we could come up with a name where the
default case cuz the default case
otherwise not useful the one argument
case it's frankly not useful um I mean
okay so here's a weird name sequential
operator
it's a totally weird name but you know a
sequential operator form of blah that
accepts okay let's try let's just say
okay because we're is a sequential
operator form of F that such that
um Y of X is f of X of Y and then we get
to say you know sequential operator ,
you know comma 3 2 1 is a sequential
operator form Y is the default reversing
those args because it's not useful
otherwise so it's head then Arg - then
Arg 1 0 0 - 1 that's correct it's not
useful otherwise otherwise all it's
gonna do otherwise it's a very arbitrary
- argument thing that I don't think is
very useful all right that accepts that
assembles a function from a sequence da
because that's going to assemble
something that particular thing curry 3
2 1 we'll take the first thing that it
gets here right and put that as the
third argument is that correct yes it
would premiered the arguments before
applying F so this is X Y Z will give
could whoever's on got background noise
please mute will give that right yes
he use a more interesting permutation
like two three one which is not it's on
inverse and then yes what what will this
give this exactly exactly
okay well here's another weird weird
name operate a template no that's not
right either because our template
functions don't do sequential stuff that
assembles a function by sequentially
examples an expression from a sequence
of function applications what it is in
essence I mean it doesn't refer to the
fact that the arguments are being per
muted see I'm wondering whether
construct world as a way to think about
it in terms of construct or something
some word related to construct like
operator construct or sequential
construct
you
okay let's try this um without just
assemble I was thinking about things
like that but I think that that's too
obscure word construct assemble nobody's
gonna remember which does which I mean I
suppose that's really weird
curried construct it's like there's a
stir-fry
yes constructor doesn't doesn't feel
like a birth here right
well and it doesn't need to be a verb
here I mean it's a consequential
construct concentric struck on the live
stream swish cars suggesting function
bond I don't get that I don't really
think I unfortunately I think and I
think you know curried function doesn't
really do it either because it's just
there is a right name for this and we
don't have it but we should discuss yeah
yes so we have two new functions that
are implemented
okay not yet not yet merged but the
assignment seems clear you can't split
yes so this function is aligned with no
we review it sequence replace last week
okay and this function is basically
aligned with sequence split and sequence
we don't have an implementation if you
if you happen to try it we do we do not
we do not yet right of ownership here so
so it's basically like string split in
the same way that we have extended the
string functions to sequence functions
since cases and sequence to place this
is the split function yes I agree I
think this is we discussed this right
yes yes let's our pattern looks right to
me what does it do is person to most and
sub lists are not splitting the latest
stuff is the basic point yes so this is
like a sequence replace which is able to
do end replacements
and stop right okay fair enough
this is imitating string okay I'm good
with this
did we net it with the other sequence
functions okay all right and we probably
should net it with splittin things like
that we could do a final netting we
don't have to do that right this moment
okay let's look at nearest to
before haven't we a bit and we discussed
some details by email basically this is
just an operator form aligned with
greater than etc and equal to yeah let
me just check one other thing I mean
nearest to start and have these string
arguments right yes this isn't written
that okay so that
so this nearest to I see I see I see
so if the data has that then it will
work because this is just a converter to
convert her to two nearest what about
this form here yes that's the second
line well n is here meaning both N and n
Kumar
we're discussing well you probably
document that okay but I think yeah
right this is not talking about the use
in entity lookups which i think is an
important use yes we are working on that
we have discovered that we have an issue
with quantities
kasnia rest is not very nice to all be
in quantity I see I see
okay so if we specify explicitly
distance function is a quantity
magnitude then it works but we should be
correctly okay
did you notice by the way that horrible
bug in the in the cloud that I reported
today with with quantity right yes yes
so that's that's a generic it doesn't
have to be it doesn't had it's not
related sorry to the elevation it's a
genetic thing of the new mechanism for
storing data in in a race so if you do
sparse array of a large range say okay
is somebody looking at it yes I reported
it to Lou and Lou knew it and and there
is a cloud ticket for it so they are
looking at it okay good all right let's
get to the main event data
representation and data set yes so this
is a continuation of the discussion we
had last week in the last
discussion we were talking about a
constructor of a nest set of nested
associations so tony has pointed out
that it would be nice to have a lazy
version of that a container not a
constructor and thinking about it we
realize that it would be also very
useful for data set this is the idea of
a lazy data set that you have also
pointed out sometimes okay so let's walk
through what we're talking about here so
the issue is we've got a list of lists
for example and we want to Association
if I the list right like writing by
providing keys based on okay so so the
name association array has been floated
as a possible name for that house has a
generalization of Association thread is
that correct well the idea of
Association array will be the lazy
version the base or the version that
contains the data button do not does not
construct an actual nested Association
because 20 points out that it takes
quite a lot of time to construct that
Association so if you are just going to
extract some data from some some value
using keys we can do that by working
directly on the array it's built the
idea of quantity array in which we could
construct a large array of individual
quantities but others play the roles of
the units interesting what happens if
you want to mix those two ideas well
Toni was suggesting that why don't we
also do this be a structure array I'm a
bit worried that we are going to
construct a competing object with data
set because both will take a race with
keys in any love at any level so I would
prefer to have this object but to hide
it inside data set so your proposal
would be to have data set B so okay so
one possibility is to have
something where we have data set and
then we have the headers specified in
data set exactly yeah
are there another argument or options
because we don't know what's going to be
the most important thing to have in data
set second argument could be types in
the future something else
so perhaps an option is safer but yes we
do need to have the ability to specify
this and then instead of constructing
internally a nested Association which
will take quite some time for large
cases we just keep it as it is and we
know how to extract information yes and
then this would be faster okay but
that's not solving the problem of and
then what would you do you do normal of
that to get out the thing with the
actual nested associations yes or we
could have a function that does that the
constructor we were talking about last
week which constructor the the
Association thread type constructor
exactly wait a minute so so okay so look
there are two issues here one is this
notion of a lazy version of this I mean
in a sense it's datasets business how it
chooses to I don't know I'm not super
happy with this I mean okay so so the I
I think that because dataset is is even
atomic it doesn't matter how its
internally storing the data as long as
it always returns the spektr result in
any operation so if the user is passing
the data already as an astute
Association we'll leave it like that if
the user is giving us the array
separated from the headers
why reproducing again and again and
again all the internal headers that that
some blow up in memory and and Tony has
some examples in which with a-- with
with even a top-level implementation he
gets speed ups of 100 from what from
nested associations
because it takes quite some time to
construct the nested Association from
the race Tony do you have comments yeah
basically what you said correct okay
well okay so we've got the non lazy
version the immediate version which is
more of a key distribute type function I
mean it isn't really headers it's really
some kind of keys yep what are our key
related
I mean I suppose we could have a thing
you know keyless so something you had
the idea of having association thread
itself doing this it's a bit of talking
about to the dataset case if we're gonna
you know have a way of specifying this
lazily in dataset oh you're looking for
the name of the option I'm looking for
the name of the option are you saying
that Association thread could do this in
the non lazy case
well you suggested to have a list of
lists of keys in the first document and
then each sub list would apply at a
different level and this may work it's
it's it's a bit of an extension of our
concept of threading but but this could
work hmm well how would you distinguish
keys that are lists by using the head
key if needed fair enough I mean you
could also give a third argument here
which specifies which some kind of level
spec could be that would be actually
very thread-like right all right I agree
that this is that that's a reasonable
thing to do to generalize this to allow
lists does it go the right way round I
mean it's a little weird right it's no
no no this doesn't work this isn't the
threading operation yes that's what I'm
saying it's it's not truly a thread
operation as we have it in other
function because it works at several
levels at the same time I personally
prefer key distribute distribute well
isn't it
type operation well again we have the
same issue distribute also works at the
same level of the expression its
distributing an operation over another
operation it's a bit like a
transposition in which the first two
heads are different what yes like like
we do where we do distribute plus over
times or vice versa yes it's it's come
it's like changing the which it is a
more internal and which one is less
internal but it works only at two levels
well we want these at multiple levels
right
hmm well what function does that what
function other than map goes down and
applies things at many levels well
that's why I was looking for a nest here
I don't think it is not it is not a nest
but this multi-level right I mean that's
just doing the same thing or a fold you
were also talking about a fold at one
time yes yes but I meant really nest but
it's not yes I think what would we say
if it was key distribute we would say
something like um distributes the key IJ
at level I in the array in the array
distributes no users the key IJ creates
a nested Association structure
in which key IJ in which the key IJ are
the keys at level I I correct yes
so the function of
Association itself
hmm takes just a list of rules and this
would have no such thing this would be
literally a list of so this is a thing
well this is a different kind of
operation than we've had before
what's an operation in which the what
this has to do this is a mapping from
dimensions these things have lengths
which are the dimensions of the array
correct I mean there's also apply keys
be bent keys I don't believe in
preparing because it's not it's really
not it's more like it's using those keys
otherwise anybody know if we have a wait
a place to store this hmm
I don't remember that's the sort of
thing that fish might remembers very
well right um who is somebody filling in
for Sushma okay hump
well let's see if we have a section here
for data set okay so we're gonna put
this in association thread etc under the
data set yeah um okay so that whatever
this is okay so then there's also the
lazy version with data set itself right
is this an end user constructor is there
something more for I mean how is this
gonna work is this really gonna be an
end user thing
what do you mean end user well I mean as
in are people going to get datasets that
have been prepped this way or are they
going to create them I expect both
imagine an array which is a packed array
of integers say so blowing it up two
nested associations will lose the
packing and it's going to take a lot
more memory so there may be cases in
which it's more useful to prepare
datasets in this way what
the competing second arguments of data
set I'm not sure yes but I'm I'm I I
mean I imagine that type information
could be important to provide at some
point the problem is that having a you
know I just don't I mean key lists is
about the only thing that I can think of
and then we could imagine apply key
lists key lists Erol whatever inside
data set and then apply key lists to do
the actual things on an array making
sense so Tony do you see advantages of
having a separate construction here this
association array you were proposing so
I was wondering better it could be more
efficient if there's a dedicated
function but given home and how
associations are lists of them are
representing a memory that make me think
we might be the lazy version well I'm
sorry the question of whether what what
Jose is asking is is the custom
association array for some reason better
than a data set that has been annotated
to use this yes are you answering that
it is or is that are you answering that
that's the question
house I are you saying that no that's
the question the desert question exactly
starts sorry
I thought you were asking Tony no no yes
oh so I I don't know which one is better
for me currently it's an implementation
detail but
okay I mean Association array is nice in
terms of you know the fact that it I
mean then we could conceivably just have
association array it's just a lazy
version and the operation that we're
doing then we wouldn't have a specific
function for it it would just be normal
of Association array yes and one thing
I'm imagined is having keys not at all
levels but it's some levels just a list
that's gonna be headers it's gonna be
keys at one level there'll be a key key
list one and then there might be an
automatic one on yeah man is right
keyless two etc etc etc and automatic
what would that do would it would it for
example do sequential integers for the
Association
therefore we already have to position
what we already have to position so
nothing is needed you can still extract
it using an integer
we did it that way yes but the normal
form will be different so perhaps still
a leaf right and automatic will insert
one goes to something towards to
something
right now the problem with a new
construction is that if this is going to
be an array we have to work quite a lot
to propagate it everywhere and and Tony
was initially suggesting the to reuse
structure array like quantity array did
but this is another case in which it
feels a bit of an abuse I don't know I
mean that's a question of I don't really
know what I mean structural array the
work might not be right because the
array there's possible I mean finesse
the list of often nested structure of
Lists and Association it's not an array
actually because the head has to match
well you're saying that the name should
actually be array Association not
Association array right because you're
saying it's really an association in the
end
mm no basically array deaths would stop
wherever the list of the structure lists
would start being different so if it has
three key lists and then anon the radius
would be three instead of going down the
whole structure list
I don't know under a depth look the
array depth it's not an array anymore if
it has a if it has a an association it's
not an array anymore but if it's purely
Association wouldn't it be an array mmm
not really not really no so yeah I mean
therefore array Association might be a
better name than Association array a
radius of Association Association nested
gives two so by this definition but but
if we call it a reassociation then it's
not a natural type of structure array we
would have to implement
independently and it's going to be a ton
of work well having it inside dataset
has already most of the interaction with
the rest of the world prepared yes but
then okay then that again raises the
question does one want a non lazy form I
mean so okay so we've got key lists and
apply key lists it's one possibility for
those different names I have depression
that these are independent problems we
can still have the new form the internal
form of data set independently of
whether we create this external object
called a reassociation or I agree but
I'm not suggesting well I'm suggesting
apply key lists just does the thing
producing an actual nested Association
nothing lazy right yes is the operation
yeah so I mean that would be a family a
pair key lists will be the I'm a little
troubled by that because key lists to me
might more be an access or function that
gives you the lists of keys at each
level yes you might want you know yes
like each list
yeah what gives the list of keys at each
level
is Keith able to go deeper
it's listable
list the ball but if you have nested
associations is it able to give you the
keys at all levels of the an estate
association no and that also might not
work if the associations are not
rectangular I unfortunately have to go
here um and well you guys can chat about
this a little bit more this is clearly
not an eleven point three issue right
but we need to yeah I mean I right my
preference would be to say okay it looks
to me like there are three things that
are needed potentially you know either a
lazy construct of its own that can be
inserted into data set or a way to
specify this within data set an access
or function that that inverts well a a
constructor function that takes key
lists an array and turns it into a
nested Association and at the inverse of
that that takes a nested Association
extracts the key lists from it but I
have to say key list seems like a pretty
good name for the extractor yeah so an
apply key list seems like an okay name
for
yeah Sookie lists that's kind of like
dimensions and the the function that
applies dimensions to something wow what
is that we just introduced a new
function for doing that right um you
thinking of free shaping a very shape or
yes but the function that term take list
take logic lists what does the RiRi's
shape do now for this that is it's
keeping the same elements but with
different dimensionality it's basically
like flattening and then I'm flattening
two different dimensions alright I
always forget this function does it
refer to take list here it certainly
should whoops we need to add that yes
well tech list is is an extractor this
this always returns basically the same
object it's just in a different I know
but but okay so whatever we are doing
here this should be referring to a rare
shape for sure
ray I mean you know we thought about
names like a ray real label but I don't
know what label is you know call it
labels instead of keys but we call them
keys yes I think akiza's but let's see
um
I need to go I'm sorry I need to go all
right
to be continued guys okay all right see
you later